I'm gonna do this your boy sighs oh boy
aka young Draco and I'm about to answer
the internet question number one would
you rather be stuck in Jumanji or
Jurassic Park
Jumanji why I could deal with the Tigers
and the lands and bears but I can't do
the dinosaurs Triceratops and Nadia I'm
straight you were in the movie the purge
what would be your crime on your 12 hour
crime spree man I'm killing I'm killing
everything arriving everything not a fan
I'm a good person I feel like just
because you've got the power to kill
somebody and get away with it you
shouldn't do it you don't I'm saying so
I'll probably get on a private jet or
helicopter try to escape because people
gonna be trying to come get my weight
would you rather have your mom read your
mind during sex or or your girlfriend
can read your mind always all the time
you got every time you tell your girl
anything she knows when you're lying she
knows every pop OH
yo if anybody asks for anything other
than what I just asked for that question
we're gonna say would you rather have
your porn search history shared with all
your Twitter followers or your parents
again your mom would be alright on
Twitter over there people won't watch it
wash they go see you know would you
rather have a threesome with two midgets
or two seven-foot-tall chicks would you
rather go back to 18 years old with all
the knowledge you have right now or just
get a million dollars right now
I sleep Aki kaki soldier sleep that's
coming next to the bed right won't be
the one song you want played at your
funeral everybody better dance would you
rather have a giraffe's neck or an
elephant's trunk
I've already had a long neck so I could
have no jury move chains for about 30
chains it's the most logical answer yet
in that question what's the fiercest
toughest animal you could take down in a
fight no you can't eat a lion you know
liar lion would [ __ ] you up would you
rather have a roller blade on your left
foot for the rest of your life
everywhere you go sleep couch bed shower
all of it or you have a [ __ ] walking
in front of you everywhere you go
he's walking a little bit slower than
you want to walk and he's got a real bad
attitude I mean again yeah roll the
blade or the midgets always bothering
you Austin
things I want to show you if you had to
eat one human body part what would it be
by the [ __ ] ear because Mike Tyson made
it look good oh damn Mike depending like
you want to post my hot sauce on this
[ __ ] engine I'm like damn I need make
that ear look
I fight second [ __ ] ears see what that
tastes like my damn might say say it
tastes like chicken
mm-hmm that's like chicken Mike put that
put the ear on the skillet money some
ketchup let's get it would you rather
sit down with your parents and watch
every sexual encounter they ever had
uh-huh yeah it's the internet it's the
internet or or you got to watch the sex
tape but when your parents conceived you
[Laughter]
[Music]
good stuff